Last time we talked,
you were very candid about Twitter.
And how --
Yeah.
You've been having some
issues with your Twitter
account because
like some of us
you like to have a drink or two
and then get on Twitter.
And that can --
Yeah.
Lead to issues.
I've deleted my Twitter account.
(laughter)
You deleted it?
Yeah.
On my own merit,
like, no one told me,
"Kiersey, you should get off Twitter."
I just deleted it.
I just -- it's so
much going on.
And it's toxic or something.
[Conan] Yes.
It's like high school, yeah.
I can't.
I can't do it.
Yeah.
I think, I think you're --
I think you have the right approach.
You described Twitter
recently as being stuck at a bad party.
Mhm.
Is that how it feels to you?
One hundred percent.
I realized when I was saying it, too,
that now you don't get stuck at parties
because we have, like,
chauffeurs on our phones --
[Conan] Uh-huh, right.
But when I was in high school,
I would always --
my friends were so bad.
I was the good kid,
I just wanna be clear,
and we would --
they'd be like, "It's fine, girl.
Like, he's gonna drive us to the party.
He doesn't drink.
It's gonna be all good."
And then we get there and we're stuck.
He's doing drugs.
Not drinking but he might as well be.
Right.
And then you're stuck at the party
and you're like, "I don't wanna be here.
I hate everybody here.
And I keep coming back every weekend."
And that's what Twitter feels like to me.
(laughter)
Every time I'm there, I'm like,
"Why did I come back?"
And I'm stuck.
Right.
You know.
That sounds rough, Kiersey.
Let me tell you what my experience was.
Nobody invited me to a party!
(laughter)
Nobody!
No! That's the thing.
Nobody was ever invited to the party.
It's not --
It's not a party anyone's invited to.
It's like a party that ends
because you hear gunshots.
Yeah. Oh, well --
Those are the parties I was at.
That's --
that's different.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah.
No, no, I didn't --
Different high school we
went to, it sounds like.
It sounds --
well, first of all,
we went to different high schools,
but I think, and I will
be honest with you,
there were no gunshots going off in
Brookline, Massachusetts, let me say that.
But --
Well, those are the best parties.
At the same time,
if I had gone to your high school,
guess what?
No one would have invited me to a party!
(laughter)
That's --
I would have.
I would have invited you.
You would have invited me to a party?
And maybe you could have
been the designated driver
and I wouldn't feel the way that I feel.
If you would have invited me to the party,
people would have said,
"Why'd you bring that
weird white lady with you?"
(laughter)
White mom at the party.
"What's with the weird old white lady?
What is she doing here?"
(laughter)